- [Male Voiceover] This
UCSD-TV program is presented by
University of California Television.
Like what you learned?
Visit our website or follow us on Facebook
and Twitter to keep up
with the latest programs.
- [Male Voiceover] We are
the paradoxical (mumbles).
Bipedal,
naked,
large brained.
Long the master of fire,
tools and language,
but still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past.
Carta brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who
we are and how we got here,
an exploration made possible by
the generosity of humans like you.
(intense piano music)
- As humans, we often ponder
the pleasures of life.
Things like good food,
a drink with friends
after a long week of work,
falling in love.
That's a great thing in life, right?
Spending time with family.
These are all undoubtedly great things
that we enjoy in our lives.
I'd also argue that sleep is one
of those great things in our lives.
There's nothing better than
sleep when you're truly tired
and the feeling of climbing
into bed, pulling up the covers,
putting your head down and
falling asleep is pure bliss.
And we see this in cases of
extreme sleep deprivation.
For example, here's a
picture of Peter Tripp.
He was a DJ in New York in the 1950's.
As a publicity and fundraising stunt,
he tried to stay awake
for as long as he could.
He managed to stay awake
for over eight days,
which is pretty remarkable.
On the air the entire time.
What's even more remarkable to me
is that others came along
and actually beat his record.
I can't imagine why anyone
would want to do this.
But on a less extreme scale,
I bet that most everyone in this room
follows the same pattern that I do
and that is we sleep too
little during the week
and then we catch up on
sleep on the weekend.
So I bring up these examples
to illustrate the love-hate
relationship that we
seem to have with sleep.
On the one hand, we love sleep
and people often say I love sleep,
but on the other hand, we always have
something better to do than sleep.
Isn't that right?
Sleep is seen as something
that we can do without
or that we would like to do without
and certainly we cut
into it very commonly.
So just like we hear
people say I love sleep,
we also hear them say I wish I
could function on less sleep.
Today, I want to present some findings
from my lab over the last couple years
that suggest that this
love-hate relationship
is not a new phenomenon.
It's not a new phenomenon
associated with television
or social media or artificial lighting
or all the other kinds of
evils you might think of
if you're in sleep
medicine or sleep biology.
Instead, our findings are
suggesting that natural selection
has been whittling away
sleep along the human lineage
probably for millions of years.
We also think that this
might have implications
for understanding some
aspects of human health.
So I want to start with a
little bit of background.
First of all, what is sleep?
Sleep is a reversible state of rest.
So it's not like a comma.
It can be easily reversed, sleep can.
It involves reduced awareness
and responsiveness to surroundings.
It involves a rebound effect.
I just talked about that with our
catch-up sleep that many of us are going
to have tonight after
this long week of work
and travel and everything else.
You have to compensate for lost sleep.
And very importantly,
sleep is not one thing.
It's actually two different things.
When you're not awake,
you're actually in two different states.
You're in non-REM sleep or in REM sleep,
rapid eye movement sleep.
REM sleep is, of course,
when the most visual dreaming occurs.
A sleep biologist can differentiate
these two stages based on EEG.
Now I want to just walk
you through what would
be considered an ideal
or normal night's sleep.
This is showing an eight hour time period
from about 11 p.m.
until roughly seven a.m.
So an eight hour block
of consolidated sleep.
Ideally you would follow into the deeper
stages of non-REM sleep first.
You'd spend some time in
non-REM sleep and then you'd
actually arouse out of
non-REM and go into REM.
It's a different stage.
It's not just a deeper
stage of non-REM sleep.
That cycle then continues
throughout the night.
You go in a second bout
now of non-REM sleep
into deep slow wave sleep and
you come out into REM sleep.
Now periodically throughout the night,
you would also awaken.
I want to really focus
on one question today.
How does human sleep differ from
the sleep we see in other primates?
I want to be a little bit more provocative
and ask are humans evolutionary outliers
in terms of the kinds
of sleep that we have.
In terms of the
characteristics of our sleep.
And so, of course, we think
in evolutionary anthropology
a lot about how humans are
different from other primates.
Often those are questions
about discrete traits,
qualitative traits.
Bipedalism, how we use tools
or whether we use tools
or whether we have a theory of mind.
Here, I'm interested in
a quantitative trait.
The characteristics of sleep.
And so I need to first define what
I mean by an evolutionary outlier.
This is a trait that's more
extreme than one would predict
based on the modeling of trait evolution
on a phylogeny, on an evolutionary tree.
So based on what we know about
the various socio-ecological
factors that influence
sleep in primates as well as
the phylogeny and where
we fall on that phylogeny,
we can predict sleep
characteristics in humans.
So for example, we know
that predation risk
across mammals will tend
to reduce sleep times.
If animals do not have
a safe place to sleep,
they sleep less.
And so we can use that
knowledge across mammals
to actually predict what
human sleep would look like.
And then, of course, once
we have a good prediction
and some confidence intervals on it,
we can ask where does our observed value
of human sleep fall compared
to what is predicted.
And if it falls outside that distribution,
we would be an outlier.
We're different from what
you would predict based
on what's known about
sleep in other primates.
And so we use a method that's
been developed in my lab
called phylogenetic
prediction where we use
a statistical model in
phylogeny to predict a phenotype
in a particular species,
in this case humans.
We basically have a bunch
of different variables
that can go into this and
we estimate these parameters
in the model, and we also
incorporate evolutionary history.
We implement this.
We make estimates of this model using
a Bayesian approach that
produces a posterior
probability distribution of predictions.
So this is what you might
see in this kind of a case.
We use this approach and
we come up with a posterior
probability distribution of
predictions as you see here.
Then the question, of course,
is where do humans fall?
Are we above this distribution?
Is our observed sleep time
above this distribution?
We would be a positive outlier.
Or we could be a negative outlier,
the observed value falls
below this distribution.
Or we can be about what you would expect
if we were a typical primate.
So the critical question in all of this,
of course, is what value do
we put on this distribution?
So what is the duration of human sleep?
What would be a good estimate
of the duration of human sleep?
Well, here I'm gonna use
a value of seven hours
and I think that's a fairly
conservative estimate
based on several different
lines of evidence.
Some of this evidence is
from our own work studying
a traditional population agriculturalist
who live in Madagascar and they're
a population without
access to electricity.
And in this population,
I'll talk about this
in a little bit later in my talk,
we find that people sleep on average
six and a half hours a night.
We've also studied the
Hadza hunter-gatherers
and there we find that the average
sleep time is 6.2 hours per night.
Likewise, a recent study
of 300 gatherer groups
found that the average sleep time across
those three groups was 6.5 hours.
Pretty short.
These guys don't have TV, right?
They don't have all the
things that we have,
the social media and all
the artificial lighting,
and they're actually
sleeping a little bit less.
Another study of a non-electric
population also gives seven hours.
Or we can look at Western populations
and it's about seven hours
in a recent meta-analysis.
And so we think that
this is a conservative
estimate of typical human sleep.
Seven hours.
OK, so here's a picture of a Hadza man
sleeping with his fire,
some weapons next to him,
and on the ground which is different
from most other primates.
And I just want to share
with you the three things
that we found from our analysis.
First of all, humans sleep
less than would be predicted,
so we're a negative outlier,
we spend a greater proportion
of time in REM sleep,
that rapid eye movement sleep,
and we are very flexible in our sleep.
More flexible than would be predicted.
All right, so let me walk
you through the evidence
for each of these three points.
First of all, here's the distribution
of sleep times for primates
where we have data.
We have a pretty good number of species
now studied for their sleep
and what you see is that
humans are the shortest
sleeping of all the primates.
Now, again, we want to
control for phylogeny
and for these other ecological variables,
and so we've used this
phylogenetic prediction
approach that I talked about.
Here's our equation that we're using
to predict sleep duration in humans.
And here's our posterior probability
distribution of those predictions.
And what you can see is that the observed
value falls below this distribution.
We are a negative outlier.
In fact, the mean predicted sleep duration
for humans is 10.3
hours from this analysis
and we're clearly different from that.
Here's the second result
involving REM sleep.
Humans, again, have the highest percentage
of REM sleep of all the primates.
Now, again, we wanted to
use this outlier approach,
this phylogenetic prediction approach,
and so, again, here's our
equation relating REM sleep
to activity period, body
mass, brain size, diet,
interbirth interval,
group size, and phylogeny.
And you can see the posterior
distribution in this case
and here's the observed value.
So here, we're a positive outlier.
And we know that this is
achieved via higher than expected
REM sleep, so if we just look
at the total amount of REM,
we're looking here at
the percentage of REM,
at the total REM we have
higher than expected REM
and less than expected non-REM.
It looks like both of these are shifted.
OK then, the final set of
results I want to share with you
involves a hypothesis that
we came up with based on
the ethnographic literature,
based on experimental studies,
and based on the historical record,
and that is that natural
human sleep is more
flexible than we usually appreciate.
And so let me just walk you through some
of the findings that
were already out there
before we came into this sphere.
Here's an example from the
ethnographic literature,
work by Dan Everett on
the Piraha South American
hunter-gathers were reports
that the Piraha take naps,
15 minutes to two hours at the extreme
during the day and night.
There's loud talking in
the village all night long.
Consequently, it's very
difficult for outsiders
to sleep well among the Piraha.
In a more, sort of a review
article of all of this
ethnographic literature on sleep patterns,
Carol Worthman notes that
human nights are filled
with activity and significance
and nowhere do people
typically sleep from evening until dawn.
In terms of the historical records,
some of you might be familiar
with Roger Ekirch's work
in which he looked through
the historical record
in multiple cultures in Europe over
the past couple of thousand years
and found evidence in much of the written
record there for references
to a first sleep and a second
sleep with a period of
nighttime activity in between.
So he found evidence for what would
be called segmented sleep.
And likewise, in experimental studies,
for example, Tom Wehr's studies,
when he put humans into
a long night condition,
so a 14 hour condition where people were
not allowed to have access to lighting,
they shifted into a
biphasic sleep condition.
So again, segmented sleep.
Of course, other primates
also show nighttime activity,
but my colleagues and I in my lab
have hypothesized that humans are
more extreme than other primates.
Well, unfortunately, we don't
have data on other primates,
but we can look at how
flexible sleep is among
people living in traditional populations.
So as I mentioned, we've
been doing work in the Hadza.
This is work led by a postdoc
in my lab, David Samson.
We've been doing work in the Hadza
using actigraphy devices
that are just watches
basically that measure activity levels.
And from that with algorithms,
we can make inferences about sleep.
And also, in the Malagasy population,
the agriculturalists, we've
been using actigraphy,
but also EEG.
So we actually have the gold
standard measure of sleep
in one of these two populations.
And I just want to share with you
some of the things that we find.
This is a big table, but let
me focus on two elements in it.
This is total sleep duration
in the Madagascar population.
6.5 hours as I mentioned previously
compared to seven in a
typical Western population,
in this case in the USA,
using the same techniques.
Likewise, the sleep fragmentation metrics
are much higher in the Malagasy population
and sleep efficiency is much lower.
So they're up a lot more during the night.
Likewise, we found some
evidence for segmented sleep.
The same kind of segmented
sleep that Roger Ekirch
has documented in European
historical record.
So this is showing a
functional linear modeling,
the circadian patterns among
the individuals in our sample.
And this is the nighttime
hours in this population.
And what we find is a
significant bump up in activity,
especially in men, just after midnight
for a substantial amount of time, in fact.
And this is at the time
when there's over 12 hours
of darkness in this population.
So their winter.
In as well, we find in
the Hadza hunter-gatherers
that once they go to sleep,
there can often be long
periods of wakefulness
and quite fragmented sleep
as you can see from some of these plots
where the dark lines are
indicating sleep time
with the first one being
the inferred sleep onset
and then lots of activity at night.
OK, so I want to wrap
up with three questions,
very quickly go through three questions.
First of all, why are
humans such short sleepers?
What is going on with this?
Based on this, should we
be short sleepers today?
Is this giving us some
reason to think that
maybe we don't need all of this sleep?
And then finally, does the evolution
of short sleep potentially affect health?
OK, so why are humans such short sleepers?
Our answer to that is
that, just like today,
throughout human evolution,
our ancestors have had better
things to do than sleep.
Some of the potential selective forces
that might be at play
to shorten sleep along
our lineage is that we
sleep on the ground.
We know from other
species, other primates,
there's great predation
risk on the ground.
If you are experiencing
greater predation risk,
that should select for less sleep.
As well, being on the ground
may expose individuals
to greater inter and intragroup conflict
where it would be easier
for a conspecific,
another member of Homo sapiens,
to attack at night because
of this terrestrial sleep.
But as well, sleep comes
with opportunity costs
and one of those involves
social interaction.
When you're sleeping,
you're not socializing
and we know how important
socializing is for humans.
And in particular, it's
important in the context
of social learning from
the awake time to acquire
and transmit new skills and knowledge.
So we think that many of the
things that have made humans
so successful have also
favored less sleep.
Now as well, the higher
percentage of REM sleep
may relate to this last
issue because it's thought
that REM sleep also plays a role in
consolidation of memories
and simulating various
kinds of threats and problem solving.
So do these results suggest
that we should sleep less?
Should we be considering a
Paleo-sleep plan of some kind?
I think our findings and
those of others are suggesting
that a Paleo-sleep plan
would involve very short
and fragmented sleep, very
brutish in another way.
And I think we can turn
to evolutionary medicine
to help us think about this issue.
A central tenant of evolutionary
medicine as we've heard
in the previous talks is that
natural selection operates
on reproductive success, not on health.
In fact, short, fragmented sleep
is associated with many
poor health outcomes.
Those include cardiovascular disease,
higher rates of cardiovascular disease,
metabolic dysfunction of various sorts
involving diabetes, for
example, and cancer.
So there are serious problems with
having a short, fragmented sleep.
Yet, many of these problems
would actually occur likely
later in life, post-reproduction
and the selection shadow.
And so perhaps we need
to think about whether
reproductive success is more relevant
to us today or health and longevity.
If reproductive success is important,
maybe a Paleo-sleep plan is a good one.
But I bet that most people in this room
are more concerned about
health and longevity,
in which case this is
a probably a bad idea.
And in fact, I would suggest that humans
today are having the best sleep that we've
ever had in our evolutionary history.
So you can imagine that this gentleman's
having a much better sleep on average than
this individual is going to have tonight.
And there are many reasons to enjoy this.
For those health benefits I just mentioned
as well as for better cognitive function,
better immune function, et cetera.
Does evolution help us understand
modern sleep and sleep disorders?
Of course, many people
do not get to experience
this kind of nice, relaxing
sleep, consolidated sleep.
For example, many people, about 10% of
the U.S. population has
some kind of insomnia.
Based on our findings,
I guess one question
that arises is should we
really expect to sleep
through the night, every night?
That doesn't look like it's really been
a part of our evolutionary history.
That seems to be a modern
phenomenon that we strive for.
And so perhaps
middle-of-the-night insomnia
is not so unexpected, especially
for those of us that may
have ancestors who had that
kind of segmented sleep pattern.
As well, you can imagine that individuals
who experience threats
of various kinds would
have an adaptive response to not sleep.
And, of course, in modern society many
people do experience these threats.
People living in inner city
environment, for example,
or people is a relationship where
there might be domestic violence,
as well there're societal
threats such as racism.
Many people are now showing
that these kind of threats
affect people's sleep
leading to sleep disparities,
and they're even linking
that up to some of
the other health
disparities that are known,
for example, among different
racial groups in the U.S.
And so finally, does the evolution of
short sleep help us to understand disease?
Is there a case of that?
Recently, Randy Nesse,
Tuck Finch, and I proposed
that this may help us
understand Alzheimer's disease
which is thought to be
a uniquely human disease
as we heard previously in Ajit's talk.
And our idea relates to
the glymphatic system.
This is system of the brain that's only
recently been discovered
in the last several years.
It's an amazing set of discoveries.
This glymphatic system
is involved in removing
metabolic byproducts,
including amyloid beta,
which is involved, of course, as you know,
in Alzheimer's disease.
And so a lot's being
learned about this system
of how the cerebral spinal fluid moves
through the brain and
picks up various kinds
of pollutants in the brain
and carries them away.
And most importantly for our hypothesis
is that this system functions
most effectively during sleep.
So we're proposing that
this is one trade-off,
they're probably others,
of evolution acting
to reduce sleep along the human lineage.
So I hope I've convinced
you that this evolutionary
perspective is useful for
understanding this love-hate
relationship that we have with sleep.
I want to thank you all for staying awake.
I didn't see anyone sleeping.
Thank you.
And I want to especially thank my
collaborator in a lot
of this, David Samson.
(intense piano music)